(gentle music)
(birds chirping)
- [Narrator] In the
green fields of Provence,
in southeastern France,
lies a unique winery,
one operated entirely by French veterans.
(vibrant music)
The Domaine du Capitaine Danjou Winery
has 100 acres of grape vines,
and overseeing them all
right is Alan Lonjarret.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The fields and winery
are staffed by veterans
of the storied French Foreign Legion,
a branch of the French Army.
(bright music)
It is unique because it is made up
nearly entirely of immigrants.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] On the grounds,
there is also a retirement home
that has been housing and
caring for the veterans
for over 60 years.
(speaking in foreign language)
(scissors snipping)
- [Narrator] The veterans
work together in the fields
to tend to the vines
and harvest the grapes.
(speaking in foreign language)
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Residents also participate
in other activities,
including bookbinding,
ceramics, and tending to a uniform museum,
but it's the wine that's
their true passion.
It's shipped all over,
including to active legionnaires
on military bases around the world.
And they plan to keep on improving it.
(speaking in foreign language)
(gentle music)
(birds chirping)
(bright music)